is with tremendous pride that we present
this year's Sager strong award to the
undefeated Robin Roberts
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
feels good thank you thank you all oh my
goodness
ah I'm so grateful yeah this ISA thank
you so much Adam silver Stacey Sager
I am honored and I am grateful for this
recognition the words that are often
associated with this award courage faith
compassion and grace are a perfect
description of Craig Sager now the only
time that I am at a loss for words when
it comes to Craig his wardrobe I cannot
wait to wear this on the air this
doesn't wake you up in the morning I
don't know what will but I'll wear it
proudly sega style savior style is what
we call it was unmistakable and
unforgettable as is the man himself i
feel such a connection to craig we were
both young sports reporters back in the
day in atlanta in the 1980s we often
cross paths and every single time i
walked away with a big smile on my face
and often with a drink in my hand
because that was that was our craig we
were both inducted into the sports
broadcasting Hall of Fame the same year
and I was really looking forward to
seeing Craig that night but he was too
ill to attend and we were so devastated
when he passed away the very next day we
both endured bone-marrow transplants and
as you saw him incredibly blessed that
my beautiful big sister Sally Ann was a
match and she did not hesitate to step
up and help her baby's sister together
we have work to bring awareness and
increase a number of donors on the bone
marrow registry to to follow our beloved
mother's advice make your mess your
message we all have something make your
Messier message and although the outcome
for Craig was not what we hope for not
what we prayed for his journey his
valiant fight and was every bit as
powerful and meaningful to all of us who
fight on in his memory as Craig was I am
thankful for my family my partner
longtime partner sweet amber my loved
ones
colleagues who all give me strength and
encourage me each and every day and for
every one who has said a prayer for me
thank you
bless you and right back at you
mama used to say everybody's got
something a challenge that you faced
already have faced or are about to face
or will face in the future everybody's
got something even the Magnificent stars
that we have shining brightly in this
room tonight you never know what someone
is going through I urge you not to
compare your despair I don't know what
your something is but I do know that we
are all stronger than we think we are
you're more than a survivor you're what
I prefer to call a thriver Craig's
courage the way he would focus on the
fight and not the fright his unwavering
faith his compassion and grace toward
everyone he met our qualities that we
all should strive for in our lives
extending to everyone we meet think
about this no matter how seemingly
trivial the contact extend to that
person everything you've got all the
kindness understanding and love that you
can and why not do it like Craig did
with absolute joy because we remember he
came at you strong
Sager strong thank you and God bless
[Applause]
[Music]